This combo box example gets
most of the way there, but
it's missing some aria relationships.
Let's take a look at
the current situation.
>> Combo box example having
to [SOUND] choose a drink.
Combo box collapsed.
>> I'll turn on ChromeVox Lite and
then tab to the combo box.
It gets announced as Choose a drink:,
Combo box.
So far, so good.
Since this is a combo box,
I get this list of options.
I can choose with the arrow keys or
I can type.
>> Expanded.
[SOUND] Choose a drink,
combo box expanded.
>> If I were to arrow
down into the list,
I can see that the selected item was
changing but I don't hear any feedback.
Now let's see a version with a few
tweaks to make it work well.
>> Combo box example.
[SOUND] Choose a drink, combo box.
>> Just as before,
I'll turn on ChromeVox Lite and
I move to the combo box.
Now, if I use the arrow keys
to move through the list,
>> Coffee one of seven.
>> It tells me coffee, one of seven
>> Tea two of seven.
>> Tea two of seven and so on.
>> Two of seven
>> Coffee one of two, O cola one of two,
coffee one of two.
>> And if I type in co and
arrow through the list again, it tells
me that there are now only two options.
So how do we fix this?
Well, the code sample
has a few FIXME's in it.
That's probably a good place to start.
Once you've done the combo box exercise,
come back here and answer this question.